パイ投げ皆さんしたことありますでしょうか？
これは多分あれだな！
パイ投げセットって言うおもちゃなんですけど
ああこうゆうタイプね！
スプレーみたいになってて
ありがたいお皿がついてます
こうすればパイができると...
おおー！
...
まあこうゆう感じでですね...
パイ投げって言うものがあるんですけども...
普通の速度でやっても面白くないと思ったんですよ
こんな皿にね！クリームのっけてさ
パンって
こんな速度でやってても俺全然楽しめないと
思ったわけですわ！！！
はっ（笑）
楽しくねーわ！！！
というわけで今回はピッチングマシーンを準備しましたので
パイ投げをピッチングマシーンで投げると
もっと楽しいんじゃねーかと思って
パイの皿が時速１６０kmで飛ぶわけですよ！
面白いでしょ？
パイ投げを１６０kmでやったらさすがに面白いと思うので
今回はちょっとね！？
ピッチングマシーンでパイ投げをやってね
どれぐらい楽しいかやってみようと思います...
ではいこう！！！
♪
わーーはーー！！！
はーわっはっはっは！！！！！！！
はい！というわけで
ピッチングマシーンでなんですけども
かなり速いです！！！
作戦としては...
多分これ球しか発射出来ないと思うんで
どうやってパイ投げを発射しようかと言いますと...
（。。。。。。。）
これ難しくね？パイ投げ発射するの...
わあーーー！！！
今ぐらいの速度でやっていこうと思います
ちょっと速すぎて
パイ投げが本当に
殺人の道具になっちゃうんで...
これくらいの速度だったら
多分いい具合に撃てると思います
パイ投げをどうやって発射するかと言いますと...
球を入れると...
ここから射出されるので
簡単な話
パイを作って
こうやってなんか
持ちながら
球入れて
バキューってそのまま勢いで
飛んでく
ここにパイをセットして
パイをセットして
ボールを入れると...
待って...全然違う...
※虫あみを使います。
ここにセットして
電源入れます
ボールはここで受け止めてもらいます
うぁぁっ！！！あっ！！！！
ああ..ちょっと待って勢い強い！！！
パイの実？をどこにセットするかと
言いますと...
こうゆう感じで
なんかガムテープだか何かでひっつけて
射出されるボールの勢いを使って
パイの実？を飛ばすと
けどボールは飛んで行かないという
完璧なしくみでございます（ドヤ顔）
♪
こんな感じです
どう？
これ？
行きます
こんなもんかな？
行きますね♪
うぁぁぁぁぁーーーーー！！！
ちょっともう一回やってみます...
スリーツーワン...
♪（粉雪～）
うふふ...ちょっと待って...
じゃあスピードをもっと弱めよう
パイが飛んでゆくギリギリのスピードまで
でも一応皿ちゃんと飛んだよね？今？
すげーへこみ方してます
スリーツーワン...
うあああああ～
じゃあ次！最低速度でやってみます
やっ..これいける気がする！！！
行きます！！！！！
威力が強すぎて
拡散しちゃって
その場でパイが爆発するという
現象が起きてしまいます...
もうどうしようもないんで
もう最終手段として
パイでボールを作って
最後
撃ってみようと思います
ちょっと...でかい、でかい、でかい
ちょっと...
でもいいんじゃない　ほら
結構ボールぽくなってきました
おっおっおっ
おーーーー
おいおいおいーーー
来たんじゃない　これ
ちょうどいいサイズになりましたので...
しっかり結んでないから
投げて当たれば
バッ！！！ってなると思うんで
ちょっと最後は
もうこのパイの実？じゃない方です
パイのボールを投げて
ぶつかって　破裂して
もう　大成功で
終わりましょう！！！
スリー...
ツー...
ワン（手拍子）...
えっ...
いやいや　それは違うでしょ！
もっとこう
バッ！！！って来たい！　バァッ！！！って！
YO　SHI KO!
よし　コォーイ！！！
3 2 1...(手拍子）
あっ痛
エンディング
ギャャャーーーーー！！！